at certain points in their careers
actors no longer need to audition for
the roles they take eventually if
they're good enough Studios offer them
rules and they can pick and choose as
they please
however the inverse of that happens too
sometimes actors are forced to take
roles they don't want it all here are
some of the worst Channing Tatum as the
star of Magic Mike and 21 Jump Street
Channing Tatum is probably one of the
biggest names in Hollywood today so it
may come as a surprise that he hated
acting in one of the movies that helped
him become so well known GI Joe the Rise
of Cobra in an interview with Howard
Stern Tatum admitted that he was pushed
into doing that movie Tatum went on to
say that although he was a fan of the
cartoon growing up the script was not
good he also really actually wanted to
play snake eyes instead of the lead
character but he does admit that he felt
blessed for getting the work even if it
didn't open up the doors he would have
liked Edie Norton primal fear was only
the first film in a three-picture deal
that Edie Norton made with Paramount
Studios it initially wasn't a bad deal
because the film got him his start and
an Oscar nomination too soon after being
noticed numerous studios offered Norton
parts in their films and he never got
around to making another movie for
Paramount finally paramount took action
and in order for Norton to appear in
Fight Club he had to negotiate a new
deal with the studio another three years
passed and Norton had yet to agree on a
film he wanted to do so the company
offered him the Italian job after Norton
told the studio that he didn't want to
do the film the studio politely informed
him that he had to do it or they would
sue Norton complied taking the role but
he refused to do any promotional work
for the film obviously a bit angry about
the situation and you wouldn't like him
when he's angry
Natalie Portman by the time Natalie
Portman agreed to appear in Thor Marvel
Studios already had big plans they were
signing just about every actor who
appeared in their movies to multiple
movie contracts man even signed samuel
l.jackson to a multi picture deal and
his first appearance as Nick Fury was
only a cameo after the credits of Iron
Man Portman must have missed this part
of her contract as she later wanted
nothing to do with the Thor sequel when
it came time to film it of course we
can't blame Portman for not wanting to
appear in Thor the dark world when
development began in April of 2011
Portman was still pregnant and she had
made it known that she wanted to take
time off from film work to care for her
child in addition to that Marvel fired
patty Jenkins whom Portman had
recommended to direct the movie so that
didn't sit well with the actress either
while there's ample evidence to suggest
that Portman didn't want to do the film
she has since denied that she was forced
to appear in it Emily Blunt after
appearing in Fox Studios The Devil Wears
Prada many studios sought out Emily
Blunt for their films even Marvel
Studios wanted her to appear in Iron Man
2
however Fox Studios preferred that she
stay with them and appear in their
remake of Gulliver's Travels instead
starring Jack Black luckily for Fox and
unluckily for blunts her Prada contract
had a clause that required her to star
in another Fox made movie and they used
it on a movie that wound up becoming a
critical and financial bomb fortunately
blunts career wasn't damaged too much by
this movie as she has gone on to make
many successful films since then Keanu
Reeves The Watcher is proof that not all
of our friends have our best interests
at heart as Keanu Reeves learned in this
case the so called friend was Joe char
benek the director of The Watcher who
had also filmed leaves his bad dog star
wall on tour
shortly after raises huge success with
The Matrix carbonate allegedly forced
Reeves a signature on a contract to
appear in his serial killer flick rather
than deal with a long and costly legal
to
viewed and unable to prove the forgery
Reeves appeared in the watcher once the
movie was released Reeves did nothing to
promote it but for 12 months he was
contractually prevented from talking
about how he got involved in it however
once that contract was up he didn't hold
anything back saying I never found the
script interesting and revealing his
damaged relationship with the director
Whoopi Goldberg after her success with
Sister Act - back in the habit Whoopi
Goldberg was riding high when producers
approached her to star in their movie
Theodore Rex at the time Goldberg orally
agreed to appear in the movie but over
the next two years something happened to
change Goldberg's mind our guests it was
probably the animatronic talking
dinosaur she attempted to back out of it
but a previous court case involving Kim
Basinger backing out of boxing helena
caused a precedent that would have made
it very expensive for Goldberg to duck
out the actress relented and appeared in
the movie the movie did so horribly on
its test run that it was released
direct-to-video and has the distinction
of being the only direct-to-video movie
to earn a Razzie nomination for obvious
reasons
love pills fun val kilmer surprisingly
val kilmer wanted nothing to do with Top
Gun the movie that arguably shot him to
stardom it was all the result of a
three-picture deal he signed with
paramount he had completed the first two
films of the deal top secret and real
genius and owed them one more in order
to get his agent off his back
Kilmer went to meet with the film's
director the late Tony Scott according
to Kilmer he went and had the meeting
and then attempted to leave but wasn't
immediately allowed to tony ran after me
literally ran after me got in front of
the elevator elevator doors and said
he's gotta do it man
scott knew he didn't want to make a
movie but Kilmer took the role anyway we
bet Kilmer's glad he took that role now
Kilmer worked with Scott again in true
romance the entire cast of movie 43
considered one of the worst movies ever
made movie 43 has a stellar cast that
includes bad cat woman 300 abs guy House
Bunny
Wolverine jackass McLovin Stifler and
Titanic lady how the producer Charles
Wesler got all of these a list stars to
agree to such an awful movie is a bit of
a scandal Wesler responsible for lowbrow
films like Shallow Hal and there's
something about Mary somehow managed to
sign Jackman and Winslet and filmed
their scene sometime in 2009 Wesler then
used their involvement to sign the rest
of the cast but when the other actors
learned what they were involved in they
tried to get out some like Colin Farrell
and the creators of South Park Trey
Parker and Matt Stone did manage to get
out of their contracts and it's been
reported that George Clooney was able to
get out of his contract as well
apparently by telling the producers and
we quote Gogh the rest of the cast was
not so fortunate and were stuck on the
film allegedly working at scale rates is
there any crueler fate maybe just having
to actually watch movie 43 thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which star you think got
the
worse deal